sans contact avec l'extérieur, utilisaient pour aiguiser les haches.
Ces cultures qui autrefois dansaient,
aimaient, chantaient pour les dieux,
vénéraient la forêt,
tout ce qu'il en reste sont des gravures, comme vous le voyez.
Passons à l'ouest de l'Amazonie,
qui est vraiment l'épicentre des peuples isolés.
Chacun de ces points représente
un groupe isolé, sans contact avec l'extérieur.
La grande révélation est que l'on estime ces groupes à 14 ou 15,
rien qu'en Amazonie colombienne.
Pourquoi sont-ils isolés ?
Ils savent que nous existons, qu'il y a un monde dehors.
C'est une forme de résistance.
Ils ont choisi de rester isolés,
et je pense qu'ils sont en droit de le rester.
Pourquoi ces tribus qui se cachent de nous ?
Voici pourquoi.
Clairement, certaines des raisons remontent à 1492.
Mais au tournant du 20e siècle existait le commerce du caoutchouc.
La demande en caoutchouc naturel,
provenant d'Amazonie,
a entraîné l'équivalent botanique d'une ruée vers l'or.
Du caoutchouc pour les pneus de vélo,
pour les pneus de voiture,
pour les zeppelins.
C'était une course effrénée pour le caoutchouc,
et l'homme sur la gauche, Julio Arana,
est l'un des méchants de l'histoire.
Ses employés, sa société,
et d'autres sociétés comme la sienne,
ont tué, massacré, torturé, exécuté des Indiens,
comme les Witotos que vous voyez sur la droite de l'écran.
Même aujourd'hui, lorsque des gens sortent de la forêt,
l'histoire finit rarement bien.
Voici des Nukaks.
On est entré en contact avec eux dans les années 80.
En un an, tous ceux de plus de 40 ans étaient morts.
Rappelez-vous, ce sont des sociétés sans écriture.
Les anciens sont les dépositaires du savoir.
Chaque fois qu'un chaman meurt,
c'est comme si une bibliothèque disparaissait.
Ils ont été expulsés de leurs terres.
Les trafiquants de drogue se sont emparés des terres nukaks,
et les Nukaks sont réduits à mendier dans les jardins publics en Colombie.
Depuis le territoire nukak, je vais vous emmener au sud-est,
dans le paysage le plus fabuleux du monde, le parc national de Chiribiquete.
Il était cerné par trois tribus isolées,
et grâce au gouvernement et aux collègues colombiens,
il a été étendu.
Il est plus grand que l'état du Maryland
et renferme des trésors de biodiversité botanique.
Il a été exploré pour la première fois en 1943
par mon mentor, Richard Schultes,
que l'on voit ici au sommet de Bell Mountain,
dans les montagnes sacrées des Karijonas.
Voici à quoi le lieu ressemble aujourd'hui.
En survolant Chiribiquete,
on voit que ces montagnes perdues le sont toujours.
Aucun scientifique ne les a gravies.
Personne n'a été au sommet de Bell Mountain depuis Schultes en 1943.
Et on s'arrête ici, avec la Bell Mountain,
juste à l'est sur la photo.
Laissez-moi vous les montrer aujourd'hui.
Non seulement elles recèlent des trésors de la biodiversité,
non seulement elles abritent trois tribus isolées,
mais elles sont aussi le plus grand trésor
de l'art pré-colombien au monde :
plus de 200 000 peintures.
Le scientifique néerlandais Thomas van der Hammen
a décrit ce site comme la chapelle Sixtine de la forêt amazonienne.
Mais allons de Chiribiquete jusqu'au sud-ouest,
toujours en Amazonie colombienne.
Cette région est plus grande que la Nouvelle-Angleterre.
L'Amazonie est une grande forêt,
en grande partie brésilienne,
mais pas entièrement.
Descendons dans les deux parcs nationaux de Cahuinari et Puré
en Amazonie colombienne —
la frontière brésilienne est sur la gauche —
ils abritent plusieurs groupes isolés et sans contact avec nous.
Un œil exercé peut regarder les toits de ces malocas, ces maisons longues,
et reconnaître ici la diversité culturelle.
Ce sont différentes tribus.
Aussi isolées que sont ces régions,
vous allez voir comment le monde extérieur les envahit.
On voit l'augmentation du commerce et des transports à Putumayo.
Avec le recul de la guerre civile en Colombie,
le monde extérieur fait son apparition.
Au nord, l'exploitation aurifère illégale,
ainsi qu'à l'est, en partant du Brésil.
Il y a de plus en plus de chasse et de pêche commerciales.
On voit l'exploitation forestière illégale venant du sud,
et les trafiquants de drogue essaient de traverser le parc pour aller au Brésil.
C'est pourquoi, par le passé,
il ne valait mieux pas avoir affaire aux Indiens isolés.
Et si cette photo est floue,
comme si elle avait été prise à la hâte, voilà pourquoi.
(Rires)
Ça ressemble à —
(Applaudissements)
Ça ressemble à un hangar en Amazonie brésilienne.
C'est une exposition d'art à La Havane, à Cuba.
Un groupe appelé Los Carpinteros.
C'est pourquoi selon eux on ne doit pas chercher des ennuis aux Indiens.
Mais le monde change.
Voici des Mashco-Piros à la frontière entre le Brésil et le Pérou,
qui sont sortis de la forêt parce qu'ils en ont été chassés
par les trafiquants de drogue et les exploitants de bois.
Et au Pérou, il y a un commerce sale qui s'exerce.
Ce sont des safaris humains.
On vous emmène dans des groupes isolés pour les prendre en photo.
Quand vous leur donnez des vêtements, des outils,
vous leur donnez aussi des maladies.
On les appelle les « safaris inhumains ».
Ce sont des Indiens à la frontière du Pérou,
que des vols sponsorisés par des missionnaires ont survolé.
Ils veulent s'immiscer et en faire des chrétiens.
On sait comment cela se termine.
Que faire à présent ?
Introduire la technologie dans les groupes contactés,
pas ceux non contactés,
de façon culturellement responsable.
C'est l'alliance parfaite de la sagesse chamanique ancestrale
et de la technologie du 21ème siècle.
Nous avons fait ça pour plus de trente tribus :
cartographier, gérer et augmenter la protection
de plus de 70 millions d'acres de forêt tropicale ancestrale.
(Applaudissements)
Ça permet aux Indiens de reprendre contrôle
de leur destinée environnementale et culturelle.
Ils installent aussi des postes de garde pour tenir les étrangers éloignés.
Voici des Indiens formés comme gardes forestiers,
qui patrouillent les frontières pour tenir le monde extérieur à distance.
Voici une image de prise de contact.
Ce sont des Indiens Chitonahuas
à la frontière entre le Brésil et le Pérou.
Ils sont sortis de la jungle pour demander de l'aide.
On leur a tiré dessus,
on a brûlé leurs malocas, leurs maisons longues.
Certains ont été massacrés.
Faire usage d'armes automatiques pour massacrer des peuples isolés
est la violation des droits de l'homme la plus infâme et la plus honteuse
aujourd'hui sur cette planète, et elle doit cesser.
(Applaudissements)
Mais je voudrais conclure en disant
que ce travail peut être spirituellement enrichissant,
mais il est aussi difficile et peut être dangereux.
Deux de mes collègues sont morts récemment
dans un accident d'avion.
Ils s'étaient mis au service de la forêt
pour protéger ces peuples isolés.
La question est, en conclusion,
de savoir ce que réserve le futur.
Ce sont des Urays au Brésil.
Que leur réserve le futur,
et que nous réserve le futur ?
Nous devons penser différemment.
Nous devons œuvrer à un monde meilleur.
Si le climat doit changer,
faisons en sorte qu'il change pour le mieux plutôt que pour le pire.
Choisissons de vivre sur une planète
à la végétation luxuriante,
sur laquelle les peuples isolés
peuvent rester dans l'isolement,
peuvent conserver ce mystère
et ces connaissances
si tel est leur choix.
Choisissons de vivre dans un monde
où les chamans vivent dans ces forêts,
se soignent et nous soignent
grâce à leurs plantes mystiques
et leur grenouilles sacrées.
Merci encore.
(Applaudissements)